what do you think he would say about  kind of where things are now or any of  them I think he would be terribly  frustrated and terribly terribly  distraught and just the denigration of  all of this in every way shape or form  you know he was the one that was the  kind of conscience of the Senate I  believe and his his ability to to at  least bring people together and talk  about it in whatever way he could was  very important and we've lost his voice  and consequently I saw an elected  process this year unlike anything I've  ever seen and I think many people would  say that it was the the level of  discourse especially in my own home  state that took place was it was  abominable he would have he would have I  know quite frankly would have said  enough this is this is not only wrong  but it's bad for the country